Ну я хочу в домі своєму жити! Чесне слово!
Ми його будували, щоб старість зустріти! У мене було все до дрібниць!
Це 199 тисяч! І я розум  ію, що це "єВідновлення"!
Ну, цих коштів на все не вистачає!
Бо руйнування дуже великі, і зараз все дуже дороге!
Вже в кінці закінчилися кошти.
І я просто так без надії відправив запит, хоч, може, щось компенсує держава.
Я вже ні на що більше не розраховую!
Усі ці українці мають пошкоджене або повністю знищене російськими військами житло.
Чи можна його відбудувати за підтримки держпрограми "єВідновлення"?
Чи справді вона працює? Кому і за яких умов дадуть гроші?
Пані Лариса досі не може повірити, що чує ці звуки відбудови у себе в оселі.
Понад рік вона разом з родиною мешкала серед руїн,
які по собі лишили російські окупанти в Ірпені в березні 2022 року.
Мої діти стояли на вулиці, коли летів снаряд.
Я до 30-ти б не дорахувала, коли вони забігли в хату
і закрили двері. І снаряд влетів у ванну.
Будинок був пошкоджений, вікна всі пошкоджені,
дах весь пошкоджений - все текло в хату.
В мене просто було таке: "Звідки я візьму фінанси, щоб відновити свій будинок"?
Персик побитий, яблуня побита,
але бачите - все одно є яблука, все одно є життя!
Цей сад - єдине, що родині жінки вдалося відновити тут самотужки.
На інше коштів не було.
Заміна фасаду і покрівлі нині відбувається за рахунок держави.
У травні пані Лариса онлайн подала заявку на програму "єВідновлення",
за якою їй пообіцяли компенсацію до 200 тисяч гривень.
І тут дзвонять, кажуть, що у мене є пільга -
в мене цукровий діабет, я з інвалідністю і в мене син з інвалідністю,
але що так швидко це буде!
Зразу на другий день була комісія, вони все зафіксували.
Заміряли, зробили. І буквально три тижні і ми отримали!
Це 199 тисяч! І я розумію, що це "єВідновлення"!
Та коли справа дійшла до використання коштів,
жінка змогла придбати виключно певний перелік товарів
у обмеженій кількості магазинів, передбачених програмою.
Втім, отриманих 199 тисяч від держави і так не вистачило на заміну вікон,
дверей та частково ще одного фасаду.
Цих коштів на все не вистачає, бо руйнування великі, а все дороге.
На якому етапі у нас робота? Що ви сьогодні зробили?
- Сьогодні зашиваємо стіни гіпсокартоном.
Будівельники тут теж найняті за кошти з "єВідновлення",
що є додатковою можливістю програми.
Не на камеру жінка каже: приходять нерегулярно
і через це роботи вже затягнулися на два тижні.
Однак пані Ларису тішить, що робота таки зрушила з місця
у неї та в сусідів, що також отримали державні компенсації.
Загалом відшкодування до 200 тисяч гривень вже
отримали трохи більше 5 тисяч українців.
Серед них - жодної людини у цій сусідній громаді.
Тут, у селі Горенка на компенсацію від держави
ще у травні подали понад 700 заявок.
З них опрацьовано менше третини.
Люди не до кінця розуміють процедуру,
не подають всі ті документи, які вимагає постанова Кабінету міністрів:
не надають право власності, або право власності на земельну ділянку,
фото і відеофіксацію. Це трошки затягує процес.
Пані Лариса - місцева жителька і членкиня комісії "єВідновлення",
яка оглядає будинки після отримання запитів.
Разом ще з кількома членами громади
вона ухвалює рішення:
яку суму відшкодування має отримати окрема родина.
Проходьте!
У дворі пана Анатолія вже не видно всіх ушкоджень
від уламків російських снарядів.
Вікна та двері чоловік замінив за власні кошти.
Вже в кінці закінчилися кошти.
І я просто так без надії відправив запит,
хоч, може, щось компенсує держава.
Подав заяву в "Дії" я 11.05.23.
Тижні два тому прийшли сповіщення з "єВідновлення".
Побитий фасад - підраховує комісія -
теоретично вдасться відновити за кошт "єВідновлення" -
147 тисяч гривень.
Все це треба знімати, далі я бачу - підшивка.
Буває так, що порахують заміну покрівлі металочерепиці
до 100 тисяч гривень, починають міняти,
а там треба міняти стропильну систему повністю
або частково. Ну це складно вирахувати.
Кошторис для нарахування виплат комісія створює
на основі готових шаблонів, в яких написано,
скільки в середньому грошей потрібно
на той чи інший вид ремонту,
а на сайті програми вказаний перелік магазинів,
де купити матеріали. Пану Анатолію не віриться,
що така відбудова буде ефективною в його випадку.
Вони сказали: "Так, ми вам скажемо, в яких організаціях
купити цей матеріал і які організації це будуть робити".
Чому я не можу знайти матеріал в якомусь іншому місці,
де він дешевше, де мені якість подобається?
Хай обирає: чи подобається йому ця пропозиція разом з матеріалами.
У профільному міністерстві, яке реалізує програму
відшкодувань, запевняють: такі обмеження запровадили,
аби люди витратили гроші дійсно на відбудову,
а не на якісь інші потреби.
Цей фактор вплинув і на те, що чиновники відмовилися
від початкової ідеї встановити більший ліміт виплат -
пів мільйона гривень -
і ще дискутують, коли дати можливість людям
отримувати таку суму.
500 тисяч, про які ми говоримо,
вони і закладені в філософію компоненту
по "єВідновленню". Від двохсот до п’ятисот трохи
складніше будуть моменти по моніторингу їх
використання, тому що сума значно більша.
Проблема використання будь-яких сум відшкодування -
кажуть фахівці будівельної галузі -
це стабільне здорожчання вартості будматеріалів
у зв’язку з їх дефіцитом та інфляцією.
Що стосується великого буму відновлення,
то його наразі не буде, доки не буде
завершення військових дій в Україні.
Що стосується поточного відновлення об’єктів -
на це потрібна велика кількість будматеріалів,
наразі країна імпортує такі складові, які в нас…
В нас не вистачає таких матеріалів!
Усе видно на практиці: відбудова частково пошкодженого
житла в багатьох випадках потребує суми,
більшої за закладену першою хвилею "єВідновлення " -
200 тисяч гривень. Це констатують у комісії в Горенці,
розглядаючи свіжі заявки.
Це от те, що подають: заміна дверей, заміна вікон,
частково замінили, частково ще потрібно.
От з цією покрівлею вона не влізе в 200 тисяч,
тут повністю потрібно цю частину перекривати.
Після огляду комісією житла це одразу сказали
і пані Олені. Вона та її родина у 2014 році
втратили домівку на Луганщині,
а минулоріч російський снаряд майже повністю знищив
нову оселю у Мощуні на Київщині.
Ну я хочу в домі своєму жити! Чесне слово!
Ми його будували, щоб старість зустріти!
У мене було все до дрібниць!
Не чекаючи допомоги держави, кілька місяців тому
родина почала відбудову дому за власний кошт.
Ось майстерню мені зробили, просто це все моє приладдя.
Ось бачите! Це буде моя майстерня:
дому ще нема, дах не покритий,
а тут у мене будуть стелажі!
Усі чеки з ремонту Олена зберігає,
втім з шоком думає про вже витрачену суму.
Оооо! Боже!
Ви що! Скажу: не один мільйон гривень!
Таким, як Олена, держава теж компенсує
витрати за здійснені самостійно ремонти.
Проєкт ініціативи вже готують, каже заступниця міністра
розвитку громад, територій та інфраструктури.
А гроші, на її думку, люди зможуть отримати
вже цього року. Також для тих, хто зовсім
не відбудовував знищені оселі,
вже з першого серпня запрацювала програма
компенсацій за повністю зруйновне житло.
Це нова хвиля "єВідновлення", за якою
можна отримати сертифікати на повну
відбудову або купівлю нового дому чи квартири,
рівноцінних за вартістю зруйнованих квадратних метрів.
Людина самостійно обирає місце розташування,
характеристики квартири - будь-що!
З кінця вересня поточного року люди зможуть
реалізовувати сертифікати.
Це відбудеться у поточному році.
Крім того, у поточному році ми плануємо
впровадити механізм компенсації
за знищене майно на окупованих територіях.
Перед тим, як продовжувати програму,
каже одна з авторок закону про компенсації -
депутатка Олена Шуляк, варто врахувати недоліки
першої хвилі. Зокрема, низьку активність
роботи комісій, як-от у Києві, на Харківщині
та на Херсонщині, а також проблеми
старшого покоління з подачею заявок онлайн
і втратою деякими українцями
необхідних документів.
Люди виїхали, не завжди з собою взяли документи,
документи згоріли в домівці, яка знищена.
Таких випадків досить багато.
Законодавством передбачено,
що коли немає правовстановлюючих документів,
потрібно звернутися до суду.
Ми знаємо, що наші суди можуть справи
розглядати справи рік, два, п’ять.
Ми зараз з міністерством юстиції,
з коелгами народними депутатами
розробляємо зміни до законодавства
у вигляді спрощеного судового
порядку саме для таких людей.
Попри можливі вдосконалення,
наразі вже точно відомо:
будь-яким з варіантів компенсації
українці зможуть скористатися лише один
раз і лише за одним з напрямків.
Тобто, відшкодувати і вже наявні власні
витрати, і доробити ремонт за кошти "єВідновлення"
не вийде. Тоді виділених державою грошей,
запевняють у профільному міністерстві,
точно вистачить усім.
Наразі це понад пів мільйона українців,
які офіційно зареєстрували пошкоджене
чи знищене житло. Ті, хто не може чекати
на державні кошти, продовжують
звертатися по допомогу до волонтерів
та благодійних фондів, як це зробив пенсіонер
з Ірпеня - пан Микола.
Я вже ні на що більше не розраховую!
Це все-таки люди!
Коли люди не вимагають у тебе навіть паспорта,
немає розмови про гроші!
Чого б не допомагати?
В нас дуже багато таких будинків,
і все тримається на волонтерах.
Рік тому я сама собі ставила вікна,
за свій рахунок, я ж розумію,
що це не ті гроші і не так легко
дістати їх з держави.
Заявок від власників пошкодженого
або знищеного житла настільки багато,
каже координатор волонтерів-будівельників,
що комусь змушені відмовляти.
Ми працюємо з фондами благодійними,
міжнародними, локальними українськими,
з бізнес-сегментом.
Фонди розглядають заявки і там узгоджують:
якісь узгоджують, якісь ні.
Оцей будинок узгодили,
нам надали весь необхідний матеріал,
ми приїхали і робимо роботу.
Попри труднощі відбудови,
які чекають і на таких, як Лариса,
що вже витратила компенсацію
від держави на частковий ремонт,
жінка вірить: зрештою,
всі матимуть оновлене житло.
Втім, де самій брати кошти на решту ремонту -
поки не знає.
Живемо! Живемо далі, віримо в перемогу,
що воно все зміниться і так не буде.
Ну я так вірю! Може, ви колись приїдете,
а в нас буде тут краса, неймовірна!